Katrina:  我住西直门
Katrina: I live in Xizhimen.
Nicous: 不是我讲的是那个动物园
Nicous: No, I was talking about that zoo.
Lucia:然后我最近刚好比较闲
Lucia: And I've been pretty free recently.
Katrina:  野生动物园
Katrina: The wildlife zoo.
Nicous: 嗯
Nicous: Hmm
Jack: 然后就来玩一下
Jack: Then let's just play a bit
Nicous: 我草才跟我说
Nicous: Damn, you just told me
Katrina:  真假啊你说24号
Katrina: Really? You said the 24th
Katrina:  我以为我之前跟你说过呢
Katrina: I thought I told you before
Nicous: 他男的女的
Nicous: Is it a guy or a girl?
Katrina: 他是谁啊
Katrina: Who is it?
Lucia:其实我还以为
Lucia: Actually, I thought
Nicous: 我学长他问我
Nicous: My senior asked me
Lucia:我刚开始还以为
Lucia: At first, I thought
Lucia:小红书难道是你发的吗
Lucia: Was it you who posted on Little Red Book?
Nicous: 他问我
Nicous: He asked me
Jake: 嗯有什么差别
Jake: Hmm, what's the difference?
Jake: 反正字是我写对
Jake: Anyway, I wrote the words, right?
Katrina:  为啥要凑人啊
Katrina: Why do we need more people?
Lucia:主要是我感觉你不是像
Lucia: Mainly because I felt you weren't like
还得摇人是什么意思
What does it mean to gather people?
Katrina:  还得摇人是什么意思
Katrina: What does it mean to gather people?
下周再有空就去动物园
If we have time next week, let's go to the zoo
感觉气质像小红书的
Feels like the vibe of Little Red Book
哦哦气质不对是吧
Oh, the vibe is not right, huh?
动物园吗
The zoo?
Jake: 啊哦哦
Jake: Ah, oh, oh
Jake: 气质不对是吧
Jake: The vibe is not right, huh?
还有谁啊
Who else?
Jake: 不应该有小红书
Jake: Shouldn't there be Little Red Book?
Nicous: 我一个朋友
Nicous: A friend of mine
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Lucia:我不是这个意思
Lucia: That's not what I meant
Nicous: 还得摇一个人
Nicous: Need to gather one more person
Nicous: 因为他想让我不单独捞着
Nicous: Because he doesn't want me to be alone
Lucia:因为感觉您比较卡皮扒拉是小红书
Lucia: Because you seem like the type for Little Red Book
Tasha: 但是无所谓啊
Tasha: But it doesn't matter
Lucia:您的气质要这个
Lucia: Your vibe is like this
Nicous: 他们俩情侣你们俩情侣
Nicous: They are a couple, you are a couple
Jake: 小红书是一个J
Jake: Little Red Book is a J
Nicous: 他俩情侣玩为什么要带你啊
Nicous: Why would the couple want to bring you along?
Katrina: 他俩情侣玩为啥要带你啊
Katrina: Why would the couple want to bring you along?
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK
Nicous: 因为他俩单独出去
Nicous: Because the two of them went out alone.
Lucia:我们最近使用这个理论
Lucia: We've been using this theory lately.
Nicous: 他俩还没有正式成为情侣
Nicous: They're not officially a couple yet.
Lucia:来合理跨界的各种行为
Lucia: To rationalize various behaviors crossing boundaries.
Katrina:  哦哦就带你就相当于
Katrina: Oh, so taking you is like...
Jake: 对对对太合理了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's totally reasonable.
Jack: 我这个我好像是看出来了一点
Jack: I think I kind of figured it out.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh oh.
Nicous: 都是北邮的
Nicous: They're all from Beiyou.
Nicous: 哈哈你被四个北邮人包围
Nicous: Haha, you're surrounded by four Beiyou people.
Katrina:  我这辈子跟北邮人脱不了关系
Katrina: I'll never get rid of my connection with Beiyou people in this life.
Nicous: 注意乘坐野生动物园
Nicous: Pay attention when visiting the safari park.
Lucia:野生动物园
Lucia: Safari park.
Jack: 又诞生了什么新的野生动物园
Jack: What new safari park was created this time?
Katrina:  如果23号去找那个北邮男生说清楚
Katrina: If you go to see that Beiyou guy on the 23rd and make things clear.
Katrina:  如果我们俩在一起了
Katrina: If we get together...
Katrina:  就多待在北京多待一天哦
Katrina: We can stay in Beijing for an extra day.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Nicous: 噢
Nicous: Oh.
Katrina:  就是也是动物园
Katrina: It's like another zoo.
Katrina:  然后他说他也去了
Katrina: And he said he also went.
Nicous: 原来他是置中一下
Nicous: So he’s just in the middle of it.
大家快去助攻一下他也去
Everyone: Go help him out, he’s also going.
Jake: 他也去他是
Jake: He's going too, he's...
Katrina:  他 不是
Katrina: No, he’s not.
Jake: 为什么去
Jake: Why is he going?
Katrina:  他是他他有一个学长跟他
Katrina: He has a senior who’s his ambiguous interest.
Katrina:  学长跟他的暧昧对象还没有在一
Katrina: The senior and his crush aren’t together yet.
Katrina:  起但是又不想太尴尬就摇了他
Katrina: But they don’t want it to be too awkward, so they invited him.
Katrina:  然后他又不想让他落单
Katrina: He didn’t want to leave him alone.
Katrina:  就是说他可以再喊个朋友
Katrina: So he said he could bring another friend.
Katrina:  他说如果我我俩承认
Katrina: He said if we admit it...
Katrina:  他说他不介意他再带一对情侣
Katrina: He wouldn’t mind bringing another couple.
Katrina:  就这意思
Katrina: That’s what he meant.
Katrina:  他们有车去
Katrina: They have a car.
Jack: 我还以为说他是来这个专门作乐的
Jack: I thought he was just here to have fun.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  哈哈他还挺抽象的
Katrina: Haha, he’s quite abstract.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 哈哈谢彬竹很好玩啊我觉得
Katrina: Haha, Xie Binzhu is really fun, I think.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:工作不饱和啊关健是
Jake: The key is that the work isn't saturated.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: That's so funny.
Jack: 你这都1111期了还不饱和啊
Jack: You've done 1111 episodes and it's still not saturated?
Jack: 啊多次啊
Jack: How many times is this?
Jack: 你觉得这领导说的是人话吗
Jack: Do you think what the boss said makes sense?
Lucia:领导说的那必须是人话呀
Lucia: What the boss says has to make sense, of course.
Lucia:你说话咋不是人话呢想什么呢啊
Lucia: Why doesn't what you say make sense, what are you thinking?
Jake:今至少今天还是
Jake: At least for today, still.
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Lucia:至少到明天也得是
Lucia: At least until tomorrow, it has to be.
Jake: 对至少到明天还是
Jake: Yes, at least until tomorrow.
Jake: 至少还是当一天人
Jake: At least be a person for one more day.
Jack: 至少还有一天嘛
Jack: At least there's still one more day.
Jack: 对
Jack: Right.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: That's possible.
Jake: 后天再说
Jake: Let's talk about it the day after tomorrow.
Jack: 哇
Jack: Wow.
Jack: 贵活动真有意思啊
Jack: Your event is really interesting.
Jake: 以前看过这个吗
Jake: Have you seen this before?
Jake: 看过这段吗
Jake: Have you seen this part?
Jack: 不跟我去啊
Jack: Not coming with me?
Jake: 你你那时候应该在屋里边在
Jake: You should have been inside at that time.
Katrina: 看了看了
Katrina: I've seen it, I've seen it.
Jake: 哦看过了
Jake: Oh, you've seen it.
Katrina: 就接我的那个是吗
Katrina: The one that came after me, right?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jack: 这个屏幕的主意是谁想出来的
Jack: Whose idea was this screen?
Jake: 你说小包吗
Jake: Are you talking about Bao?
Jack: 这个欢迎
Jack: This welcome.
Jack: 大屏幕啊
Jack: The big screen.
这我我2022年
Jack: This, in 2022.
Jake: 这我我2022年
Jake: This, in 2022.
Jake: 在在在在
Jake: In, in, in.
Jake: 这个在特拉维夫
Jake: This in Tel Aviv.
Jack: 这个在W202 ECCD best student bag
Jack: This at W202 ECCD best student bag.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jack: 不是
Jack: No.
Jake: 这是这么回事
Jake: This is how it is.
Jake: 这推特上面啊
Jake: On Twitter,
Jake: 是这么回事
Jake: this is what happened.
Jake: 是这个计算机会议啊
Jake: It was at this computer conference.
Jake: 那那帮研究员他们一边开会
Jake: The researchers were having a meeting,
Jake: 然后大家觉得闲无聊开了一个
Jake: and they got bored, so they started dancing.
Jake: 就是就是就是蹦迪
Jake: Like, really, they started dancing.
Jake: 在会场蹦迪
Jake: They danced at the venue.
Jake: 然后我就带了一个这个包
Jake: And I brought this bag,
Jake: 然后过去上面就就就晃悠晃晃那个
Jake: and I was just swinging it around.
Jake: 就是
Jake: You know...
Jake: 那我给你给你看吧
Jake: Let me show you.
Jake: 我很难描述这个事情
Jake: It's hard to describe.
Lucia:这么久远的记录你居然还能很快找到
Lucia: You found this old record so quickly.
Jake: 推特哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Twitter, hahaha.
Lucia:哦行吧行吧打扰了
Lucia: Alright, alright, sorry to bother you.
Jack: 我去
Jack: Oh my god.
Lucia:我还以为他文件分更别类就放好了呢
Lucia: I thought he had his files categorized and stored properly.
Jake: 那你可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Jack: 不是不是
Jack: No, no.
我说作为一个搞计算机的
Unidentified Male: I mean, as someone who does computer stuff,
Jack: 作为一个搞计算机的
Jack: As someone who does computer stuff,
Jack: 不应该都有一个技术
Jack: shouldn't you have a system?
男嘉宾:那个二楼的GoPro的卡要拆吗
Male Guest: Do we need to remove the GoPro card on the second floor?
Jake: 要拆要拆都拆
Jake: Yes, remove it, remove them all.
Jake: 全部拆掉吧
Jake: Remove everything.
Jack: 你不应你不应该有全套gate吗
Jack: Shouldn't you have a complete system?
Jake: 有啊但是很多上不了gate哈
Jake: I do, but many can't be put into the system.
Jack: 你都干了些什么呀
Jack: What have you been doing?
Jake:明天录明天录对
Jake: We'll record it tomorrow, yes.
Jake: 好知道哪了
Jake: Alright, where were we?
Violet: 加进来然后他里面的那个参考文献
Violet: Add it in, and then sort out the references.
Violet: 都要重新重新的整理起来
Violet: They all need to be reorganized.
Violet: 先把这个这个参考文献找出来
Violet: First, find these references.
男嘉宾:谢彬竹 谢彬竹 谢彬竹
Male Guest: Xie Binzhu, Xie Binzhu, Xie Binzhu.
Violet: 好加到参考文献里面
Violet: Okay, add it to the references.
Violet: 然后把这边的这个序号的改一下
Violet: Then, change the numbers here.
Violet: 就这部分
Violet: Just this part.
Violet: 然后内容就完成
Violet: Then the content is done.
Jake: 来找着了
Jake: Got it.
Jake: 就在这个地方
Jake: It's right here.
Jack: 这个这个壁纸是什么
Jack: What's this wallpaper?
Jack: :打个盒子这个好好吃啊
Jack: This boxed meal is so delicious.
Jake: 对哎我靠这声音怎么整啊
Jake: Right, oh man, how do we deal with this sound?
Jack: 哦牛
Jack: Oh wow.
Lucia:牛啊
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia:这声是你换的
Lucia: Did you change this sound?
Jake:对对am在妮子yell也要换
Jake: Yes, yes, am also changing the yell.
Nicous: am在妮子
Nicous: Am also.
男嘉宾:哎我们只用到二楼的吗
Male guest: Hey, are we only using the second floor?
Jake: 然后大概就是在大概就是那一天
Jake: So basically, it was on that day.
男嘉宾:谢彬竹
Male guest: Thanks, Bin Zhu.
Jake: 搞了一个这个包
Jake: Got this bag.
Jake: 然后上面一些跳舞就被人给举了起来
Jake: And then some people were dancing and got lifted up.
男嘉宾:我怎么感觉不够
Male guest: Why do I feel it's not enough?
Jake: 对对对辛酸对哦
Jake: Yes, yes, bittersweet, indeed.
Katrina: 这是你吗
Katrina: Is this you?
Jake: 对这是我
Jake: Yes, it's me.
Jake: 我背了一个这个包去开会
Jake: I carried this bag to the meeting.
Jake: 然后被主办方给捕捉了
Jake: Then the organizer captured it.
Jake: 到最后就火了一下
Jake: And it went viral for a bit.
Jack: 你这么阔一个包
Jack: Such a big bag you got.
Katrina: 哇好帅啊
Katrina: Wow, so cool!
Jake: 当时在拧那个牌子的时候
Jake: At the time, while twisting that sign,
Jake: 然后主办方拍了一张拍了一段
Jake: The organizer took a photo and a video.
Jake: 就这个推特
Jake: It was posted on Twitter.
Jake: 就是那个会议的最高点赞的一个推特
Jake: It became the most liked tweet of the conference.
Jack: 对对严肃的会议
Jack: Yes, a serious conference.
Jack: 大家是看不好也不
Jack: People either liked it or didn't.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, indeed.
Katrina:  你这包里天天装啥呢
Katrina: What do you carry in this bag every day?
Katrina:  一个男生天天带个包
Katrina: A guy carrying a bag every day.
Nicous: 这包好看吗
Nicous: Is this bag nice?
Katrina: 好看啊
Katrina: Yes, it's nice.
Katrina:  唉这蛋糕还能明天吃吗
Katrina: Hey, can this cake still be eaten tomorrow?
Nicous: 这包星巴克送的
Nicous: This bag is from Starbucks.
Katrina: 星巴克送
Katrina: From Starbucks?
Katrina:  这 哦 修硕
Katrina: Oh, Shure.
Katrina:  哎修硕不是要停了天走吗
Katrina: Hey, isn't Shure leaving soon?
Katrina:  修硕不是要回去吗他的东西怎么没收啊
Katrina: Isn't Shure going back? Why hasn't he packed his stuff?
Katrina:  感觉他就是蒙了有点
Katrina: Seems like he's a bit confused.
Jack: 老板摸了一天鱼了终于开始干活了
Jack: Boss has been slacking off all day, finally starting to work.
Jake: 老板我也到夜里11点上班
Jake: Boss, I also start working at 11 PM.
Jake: 让你们11点下班
Jake: Let you guys finish work at 11.
Nicous: 这要关起来吗
Nicous: Should we close this?
Jake: 我来关我来关
Jake: I'll close it, I'll close it.
Nicous: 一楼的也没关那你
Nicous: The first floor isn't closed either, you know.
Katrina:  这个拿保鲜膜弄一下再放
Katrina: Wrap this with plastic wrap before putting it in.
男嘉宾:这只有手动吗
Male Guest: Is it only manual?
Katrina:  放进去不
Katrina: Should we put it in?
Jake: 不要手动不要手动
Jake: No manual, no manual.
Lucia:这放明天应该不会坏吧
Lucia: If we leave it till tomorrow, it shouldn't spoil, right?
Katrina:  但是感觉冰箱很多细菌
Katrina: But it feels like the fridge has a lot of bacteria.
Jake: 不要手动啊no手动
Jake: No manual, no manual.
Lucia:你不回吗我们准备休息了其实对
Lucia: Aren't you going back? We're about to rest.
Jake: 我好像关了我好像全关了but but 9没关
Jake: I think I closed it, I think I closed everything, but but 9 isn't closed.
男嘉宾:but
Male Guest: But...
男嘉宾:11也没关
Male Guest: 11 isn't closed either.
Jake: 哎呦我靠好好好稍等稍等
Jake: Oh man, okay okay, hold on, hold on.
男嘉宾:只要亮的没关
Male Guest: Only the ones with lights are closed.
Jake: 亮的就是没关
Jake: If it's lit, it's not closed.
男嘉宾:15也没关
Male Guest: 15 isn't closed either.
Jake: 那就是我靠
Jake: Oh man...
Jake: 怎么这么没关啊
Jake: Why are so many not closed?
Lucia:好好好先把这个送给你
Lucia: Okay, okay, first give this to you.
Jake: 我先关9
Jake: I'll close 9 first.
Jake: 别别别着急no worry
Jake: Don't rush, no worry.
Lucia:这个你挑一个吧
Lucia: You pick one.
Lucia:那个他要
Lucia: He wants that one.
Lucia:那个他要放在门口
Lucia: He wants to put that one at the door.
男嘉宾:好的好的
Male Guest: Okay, okay.
男嘉宾:不要让他变成可怜的那个没有CP的
Male Guest: Don't let him become the poor one without a CP.
Lucia:今天他今天他还和CP拍了照是吧
Lucia: Today, he took a picture with his CP, right?
男嘉宾:是的
Male Guest: Yes.
Lucia:然后看他们俩多可爱
Lucia: Look how cute they are together.
还能再摆一天男嘉宾:
Male Guest: They can last another day.
Jack: 就多一天的CP寿命是吧
Jack: So, they get one more day of CP life, right?
Lucia:那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Lucia:一天也是天
Lucia: One day is a day.
Lucia:这个这个这
Lucia: This, this, this...
Lucia:我们要给这个狗建立因果联系
Lucia: We need to create a causal relationship for this dog.
Lucia:我和把它做出来了
Lucia: I made it.
Lucia:就是突然消失
Lucia: Then it just disappeared.
Lucia:要一定要等到我们这个数据采集完之后
Lucia: We have to wait until our data collection is finished.
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Jake:好 好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia:要不然哎呀
Lucia: Otherwise, oh no.
Lucia:这想不通
Lucia: This doesn't make sense.
Lucia:怎么没了呢
Lucia: How did it disappear?
Jack: 七天没没白练
Jack: Seven days didn't go to waste.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jack: 七天没白练
Jack: Seven days didn't go to waste.
Jake:没白练
Jake: Didn't go to waste.
Katrina:  七天AI速成营
Katrina: Seven days AI crash course.
Jack: AI速成营
Jack: AI crash course.
Jack: 我看是你的
Jack: I think it's yours.
Lucia:不是这感情这跟训练我似的
Lucia: No, it feels like training me.
Jake: 哈哈哈是啊
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Katrina: 7天AI
Katrina: Seven days AI.
Jake: 咱现在有6个AI
Jake: We now have six AIs.
Jack: 真的我觉得你比AI训练的成功
Jack: Really, I think you trained better than the AI.
Jake:AI其中一个
Jake: AI is one of them.
Jake: 哈哈哈完了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over.
Lucia:哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahaha, right.
你你你比你比那个
You, you, you're better than that.
Jack: 我看见那个拆个TPT
Jack: I saw that dismantling TPT.
Jack: 那玩意还成功一点
Jack: That thing is more successful.
Lucia:那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Lucia:拆TPT上七
Lucia: Dismantling TPT on seven.
Katrina:  七天零基础带你入门AI
Katrina: Seven days zero foundation to learn AI.
Jake:哈哈哈从入门到AI
Jake: Hahaha, from beginner to AI.
从入门到从入门到入土
From beginner to, from beginner to the grave.
Katrina: 哈哈哈从入门到入土
Katrina: Hahaha, from beginner to the grave.
Jake: 从入门到入库
Jake: From beginner to the warehouse.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈入库
Jake: Hahahahaha, warehouse.
Jack: 入库像话吗
Jack: Warehouse, are you serious?
Jack: 十
Jack: Ten.
Nicous: 十
Nicous: Ten.
Katrina:  我摘了我要下班了
Katrina: I'm taking off, I'm off work.